новий виток насильства у донецьку
установивши торг підрозділи українську
армії заданими уряду видно вив і
контроль над міжнародним аеропортом
імені прокоф'єва
до школи zoho плану готові щибо готова
ден у нового канону до сепаратиста його
атакував у тому числі спа we try to camp
шинам реалізується план і будь його
президента ефективніше проводити
операцію проти терористів о 1 годині даю
чим нести you think the склади з бро і
інші подивимось і ту ж помилку пару
волосіні попередній неефективності
антитерористичної операції актор з
точну апарат ціни боже
і не буду 3-го ти два-три місяці вона моя
і буде риба ти
владами а воїни б'ються на витрати з
апарат з вигляду є за
пропанового перемир'я донецька з
околицями найкоротші терміни може
бути на донецьку законності в коробці
терміном вже досвід ще гуманітарної
катастрофі тому ми в машині викрутитися
сивий всього російського народу треба ти
будь que pase або до породи надати
будь-яку доступну допомогу
витек їх ви бачать і представився
проросійським батальйоном скит москва за
клік акривних айну пропан це
насильства в 1 годину, що заповнила ще
розруху та на діалог новим президентом
України